modest protests in belarus ahead of
another big rally planned for sunday
a test of will as the regime again ramps
up pressure on rebels
but the opposition leader says the
momentum for change is unstoppable
regardless of crowd size even if we
there this movement will
slow down or come down a little bit but
our people
they will not accept our president
anymore we have changed
how worried are you that tomorrow we'll
see new violence
it's my opinion just um to my opinion uh
our authorities saw that they valid the
violence they had
during those two days
didn't calm down people it just made
them angry
and they understood that they made a
great mistake
and i'm sure that
they will not do this mistake anymore
she fled to lithuania after running
against president alexander lukashenko
in disputed elections svetlana
tikonovskaya
says she'll return home when the regime
is ready for dialogue
and has released political prisoners
including her husband
if maybe even lukashenko says that he
will have dialogue
are you ready and would you be willing
to meet with lukashenko and have
dialogue
directly with him if it is the necessity
of it and i
will understand that it's necessary so
why
not and how long do you think it's going
to take
until you succeed in this mission
everybody has to understood has to
understand that
it can last as a couple of taser weeks
so
it can take a lot of time but
i believe in
in the fact that our authority
want the best for their countries and
they understand that
this crisis it has to
end and the sooner it ends the better
for country
it's a belief shared by many but the
threat
of arrest state violence and job loss is
real
after two weeks like nothing really
changed you know except for the protests
and i can see that um the active
protests are becoming like a passive
creeping resistance
and of course something like that uh
doesn't make you feel too optimistic
so right now i'm just concerned and i
keep asking myself what's next
what's next it's a question many will be
asking as they call for change
and as their president refuses to go
debra haines sky knees vilnius